cuáles de los siguientes nombres pueden
usarse para describir la figura
geométrica mostrada bueno vamos a ir uno
por uno cuadrilátero pues un
cuadrilátero es una figura cerrada con
cuatro lados y definitivamente aquí
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro lados así
que si esto de aquí es un cuadrilátero
eso fue muy fácil vamos a paralelogramo
a ver paralelogramo un paralelogramo es
un cuadrilátero en el cual los dos pares
de lados opuestos son lados paralelos y
aquí en efecto esto sucede verdad este
lado es paralelo a este lado porque los
dos hacen un ángulo de 90 grados con
este segmento de acá entonces este es de
90 este es de 90 y por lo tanto este es
paralelo a este déjame marcarlo así este
es paralelo a éste de manera similar
como este ángulo es de 90 y este también
es de 90 entonces este lado y este lado
también son paralelos y por lo tanto
esto de aquí es un paralelogramo los
lados opuestos son
paralelos muy bien ahora pasemos a
trapecio chin con trapecio es un poquito
más complicado porque de hecho pues ni
siquiera hay una decisión totalmente
tomada de cuál es la definición de
trapecio eso es bueno que lo escriba así
que déjenme ponerlo aquí abajo entonces
trapecio hay dos formas de pensar a los
trapecios trapecio vale una forma es más
restrictiva y es pedir que exactamente
un par de lados paralelos y que
exactamente un par de lados opuestos
sean paralelos entonces le voy a poner
exactamente exactamente un par de lados
paralelos
un par de lados
de la dos paralelos paralelos esta es la
definición que utiliza la mayoría de las
personas pero hay otra definición que
también se utiliza y es que al menos un
par de lados sea paralelo al menos un
par de lados un par de lados de la dos
paralelos
vale entonces es bueno las dos son
definiciones que la gente usa todavía no
hay un acuerdo de cuál debe de ser la
definitiva entonces bueno vamos a
utilizar la primera porque es la que más
se usa y entonces en la primera lo que
uno piensa para un trapecio es que tiene
que ser algo más o menos de este estilo
en donde este lado es paralelo a este
lado y estos dos no son paralelos salen
estos dos de acá no son paralelos
entonces utilizando esa definición la de
trapecio en donde exactamente un par de
lados tiene que ser paralelos pues esta
figura no es un trapecio porque tiene
este par de lados paralelos y este par
de la luz de lados paralelos como ya lo
platicamos entonces este de acá no sería
un trapecio no es un trapecio muy bien
ahora pasemos a rombo lo que se pide
para que un cuadrilátero sea rombo es
que sus cuatro lados sean iguales por
ejemplo un rombo puede ser algo de este
estilo no necesariamente sus cuatro
ángulos son iguales pero sus cuatro
lados sí tienen que serlo éste es igual
a este que es igual a este que es igual
a este y bueno curiosamente resulta ser
paralelogramo
pero bueno eso no nos interesa ahorita
solo hay que verificar que los cuatro
lados me dan lo mismo pero en esta
figura no podemos concluir que me den lo
mismo tenemos esta rayita y esta doble
rayita que pues no nos dicen nada con
respecto a si son iguales o no pero no
podemos asumir que sean iguales vale no
tenemos esa información y por lo tanto
vamos a ponerle que no no podemos
llamarle rombo a esta figura porque no
podemos decidir si sus cuatro lados son
iguales muy bien ahora pasemos al
rectángulo rectángulo lo voy a poner con
color naranja y bueno para que una
figura sea rectángulo lo que le pedimos
es que sea un paralelogramo en donde los
cuatro ángulos miran exactamente lo
mismo donde sean ángulos rectos o bien
también podemos pensarlo como una figura
en la cual los pares de lados opuestos
son para son miden lo mismo
también son paralelos perdón pero miren
lo mismo y en donde un par de lados son
perpendiculares y ya con eso los otros
también van a ser este perpendiculares
vale en este caso si sucede verdad aquí
tenemos uno
34 ángulos rectos y por lo tanto esta
figura si se le puede llamar un
rectángulo así que déjame ponerle una
palomita muy bien entonces también es un
rectángulo y finalmente bueno pues vamos
a verificar si es un cuadrado o no y
para que sea un cuadrado le pedimos ahí
hay dos formas de pensar a los cuadrados
como rombos en donde los cuatro ángulos
son iguales o sea como que esto lo
apartamos tantito y se convierte en algo
de este estilo bueno también lo voy a
girar algo así entonces rombos cuatro
lados iguales donde los cuatro ángulos
son iguales rombos rectángulos o bien
como rectángulos en donde los cuatro
lados son iguales como rectángulos
rombos vale bueno en cualquier caso
tenemos que checar que los cuatro lados
sean iguales pero como ya lo comentamos
no sabemos si aquí los cuatro lados son
iguales porque aquí hay dos rayitas y
aquí aún aquí hay una entonces pues no
no podemos determinar si los lados son
iguales y por lo tanto no podemos
determinar si es un cuadrado o no así
que no le vamos a llamar uno
sale entonces no va a ser un cuadrado
entonces en resumen si es un
cuadrilátero tiene cuatro lados si es un
paralelogramo los padres supuestos de
lados son paralelos no es un trapecio
utilizando esta versión restrictiva de
la definición con la otra sí pero bueno
con la que estamos usando no porque
tiene dos pares de lados paralelos no
sólo uno no es un rombo porque no
podemos saber si sus lados son iguales y
sus cuatro lados son iguales por la
misma razón no es un cuadrado y
finalmente si es un rectángulo porque
los cuatro ángulos son ángulos rectos